[Musica]
chi sceglie chi
ma sono davvero le aziende a scegliere i
migliori Talenti
o sono forse Talenti a scegliere le
migliori aziende
se vi chiedessi di rispondere a questa
domanda
cosa rispondereste
Pensateci non c'è fretta nel dare una
risposta ed è anche un po' l'obiettivo
del mio intervento di oggi il mondo sta
cambiando sta cambiando profondamente e
probabilmente Talenti dettano sempre di
più le regole del gioco e forse anche il
momento in cui le aziende devono
imparare ad ascoltare e ad agire Io
nella mia vita ho avuto la fortuna
Soprattutto negli ultimi anni di
lavorare tanto sulle ricerche sui dati
sulle informazioni
e quindi oggi ho selezionato alcune
informazioni alcuni di questi dati che
vorrei condividere con voi per capire e
comprendere in pochi minuti in pochi
minuti come sta cambiando il mondo del
lavoro
Ma ricordatela questa domanda perché è
importante perché ci ritorneremo
parto con alcuni dati che riguardano un
paese lontano gli Stati Uniti d'America
oggi in questo momento negli Stati Uniti
d'America il numero di posti di lavoro
disponibili è di gran lunga di gran
lunga superiore al numero di persone che
cercano un posto di lavoro
oggi negli Stati Uniti con il fenomeno
della criniera signation si sono dimesse
nel 2021 il 120% delle risorse in più
volontariamente dimesse nell'anno
precedente pensate che nel primo Quarter
nel primo trimestre del 2020 c'erano
circa 2 milioni di dimissioni volontarie
nell'ultimo trimestre del 2021 parliamo
di oltre 4 milioni e mezzo di dimissioni
volontarie un numero impressionante
soprattutto pensando che il dato di un
trimestre e Voi direte Sì d'accordo
Gianluca ci parli degli Stati Uniti di
un mondo lontano forse anche
anche troppo distante culturalmente per
essere confrontabile con nostri realtà
non è esattamente così in realtà i dati
dicono che anche in Italia anche qui
diciamo localmente si sta verificando un
fenomeno molto simile l'incremento di
dimissioni volontarie di inizio 2020 e
in assoluto il numero più rilevante ma
registrato nell'ultimo decennio 35 per
cento
E allora è chiaro che non stiamo
parlando di un fenomeno globale stiamo
parlando di un qualcosa che accade
accade anche qui accade anche da noi e
allora facciamo un passetto in avanti e
guardiamo alla prospettiva del talento e
chiediamoci
chiediamoci ma oggi quali sono le
motivazioni sottostanti queste
dimissioni volontarie e quali sono le
aspirazioni che ogni talento porta con
sé quando pensa e sceglie sul lavoro che
cosa vuole fare
e anche qui Cito dei dati Cito una
ricerca una ricerca di una grande
organizzazione elaborata su scala
globale e parto con il tema della
motivazione quali motivazioni dietro le
dimissioni di massa
ecco qui la cosa è veramente
sorprendente Nel senso che siamo ben
oltre l'aspetto retributivo ben oltre
l'aspetto materiale oggi alla domanda
Qual è la principale motivazione per
quale tu decidi di cambiare lavoro la
risposta è lo stress la risposta è
l'esaurimento la salute mentale il
Burnout la risposta è un grande senso di
isolamento
E allora facciamo un altro Passetto in
avanti e quali sono le aspirazioni che
cosa muove queste decisioni cosa c'è
dentro lo spirito delle persone che
riflettono su questi aspetti e guardiamo
alle aspirazioni
tali aspirazioni la prima in assoluto e
l'equilibrio l'equilibrio fra cosa fra
la vita professionale e la vita
personale e la seconda lo sviluppo la
possibilità di crescere di sviluppare
competenze di fare formazione e poi
andando avanti la carriera la
progressione quello che mi spetta nel
futuro queste le grandi aspirazioni e
queste aspirazioni hanno dietro anche
una bellissima lista di desideri e
guardiamo la lista dei desideri dei
talenti Qual è il primo desiderio in
ordine di importanza l'allineamento tra
i parpos dell'azienda e le aspirazioni e
le ambizioni personali
una missione comune e andando avanti la
sostenibilità un'azienda che si occupa
dell'impatto sociale delle proprie
attività e Andiamo ancora avanti la
diversità quanto inclusiva quell'azienda
quanto Ascolta quanto è qua
e poi l'empowerment il senso di
appartenenza di ingaggio di motivazione
e fa parte di un gruppo di avere un fine
più nobile più alto più elevato E per
chiudere la flessibilità parola su cui
ritorneremo anche più avanti in questa
conversazione la flessibilità ossia la
possibilità di gestirsi il proprio tempo
nel miglior modo possibile e in fondo ci
rendiamo conto che le motivazioni sono
motivazioni diverse sono motivazioni
profonde sono motivazioni che stanno
nell'animo delle persone che vanno oltre
quello che ci saremmo immaginati di
poter ascoltare E allora E allora
fermiamoci per un attimo vi ho
raccontato cosa cercano i talenti e
adesso riflettiamo su quello che stanno
facendo le imprese le aziende Le
organizzazioni io la fortuna di fare il
mestiere del consulente ne vedo che
aziende parlo con tante aziende
Credetemi ci sono tantissime iniziative
in corso attive che vanno proprio in
questa direzione iniziative in cui le
aziende hanno mobilitato anche
investitori risorse
in realtà il punto Il punto rilevante
che molto spesso siamo un livello troppo
superficiale a volte sono azioni
Lasciatemi dire forse anche un po' di
facciata sono operazioni di
comunicazione A volte rivolte
all'esterno a volte rivolta all'interno
e quindi chiaro che tutto questo ha
delle implicazioni E soprattutto non
risponde a quella visione olistica di
cui parlavo prima quella ambizione a
quella aspirazione che il talento i
talenti portano portano con loro
è chiaro quindi che c'è un punto di
match tra quello che viene promesso e
promosso e quello che poi viene agito
nel quotidiano all'interno
dell'organizzazione porto un ulteriore
esempio che mi sta molto a cuore
parliamo di diversity di Equity e di
inclusion quante aziende Secondo voi
negli ultimi anni Hanno lanciato
un'iniziativa sulla parità di genere
tantissime Credetemi tantissime forse
quasi tutte le aziende Hanno lanciato
negli ultimi anni delle iniziative sulla
parità di genere In realtà quante di
queste aziende hanno rivisitato gli
obiettivi creato degli indicatori di
misurazione monitorato l'impatto di
queste iniziative
Quante aziende hanno inserito queste
iniziative all'interno di un modello
olistico che magari affrontasse tanti
altri Temi da un punto di vista di
diverse aziende inclusione
Quante
molto poche ed è questo il punto Il
punto è che oggi
che oggi non c'è coerenza e consistenza
fra quello che si racconta e quello che
si fa
ed è quindi è qui che bisogna lavorare e
qui che bisogna trovare l'energia le
iniziative lo spazio per ingaggiare e
mantenere il tempo i rapporti con un
talento
e quindi proviamo a fare un passo avanti
e proviamo a dare una risposta che la
risposta delle organizzazioni delle
imprese Come attrarre Talenti come
assicurarsi che rimangano nel lungo
termine all'interno di un'organizzazione
Beh non c'è la risposta in questo caso
non esiste una risposta esatta non c'è
la ricetta giusta la ricetta perfetta
ma quello che voglio portare oggi come
contributo all'interno di questa
riflessione e quali sono quei principi
chiave irrinunciabili sui quali le
imprese devono lavorare con coerenza e
consistenza per attrarre e mantenere
Talenti nel tempo
e parto con un primo principio a mio
avviso fondamentale che è quello della
cultura una cultura fatta di etica di
inclusione di rispetto
e come farlo Come creare all'interno di
un'organizzazione un ambiente con questi
presupposti ma sicuramente iniziando a
ripensare alcuni processi dell'azienda
magari proprio quelli che riguardano il
mondo delle risorse umane e portare un
pizzico di etica di inclusione di
rispetto all'interno di tutti i
principali processi il processo di
recruiting il processo legato alla
formazione e performance manager quanto
importante che questo vi venga calato
all'interno dei processi e poi c'è un
secondo punto fondamentale la leadership
Come creare mettere nelle condizioni con
delle iniziative specifiche i leader di
essere sponsor di queste iniziative e di
essere esempio roll Model E poi
ovviamente creare delle iniziative che
partono dal basso che mobilitano intera
organizzazione per fare in modo che si
sente e si viva una cultura aziendale
diversa una maggiore partecipazione
C'è poi un secondo tema molto importante
il tema del senso da appartenenza oggi i
talenti Sento il desiderio di essere
parte di un progetto più grande di un
progetto comune e quindi è sul comfort
sul creare una zona di agio in cui il
cliente si sente accolto trattato in
modo equa ascoltato rispettato la
connessione la possibilità di essere
all'interno di un team di una comunità
di una famiglia professionale di un
qualcosa di più grande che consente di
scambiare informazioni con colleghi e
condividere esperienze e poi c'è il tema
del contributo di come mettere il
contributo personale al centro del
contributo collettivo e di come mettere
in sintonia il contributo individuale
con l'obiettivo comune Questo è il senso
di appartenenza e poi c'è un terzo tema
a mio avviso molto importante che è
quello della flessibilità
oggi il modello ibrido è già un modello
prevalente e nel futuro nella maggior
parte dei settori professionali sarà il
modello ibrido Quello su cui dovremo
impegnarci per migliorare l'efficacia
l'efficienza la qualità della vita
aziendale e allora è sul tema della
flessibilità che bisogna lavorare
mettendo modo al modo di lavorare
Innanzitutto e quindi ripensandolo
ponendo l'obiettivo e il risultato e non
l'attività il controllo al centro del
sistema e al centro del modello
creando una workforce che sia preparata
ad affrontare un cambiamento che abbia
quella cultura digitale quella
propensione al rischio che è
indispensabile per vivere le sfide
affrontare le sfide del modello ibrido
di un mondo di lavoro diverso ed infine
il posto di lavoro l'ambiente di lavoro
come creare spazi che promuovano che
facilitino la collaborazione lo stare
insieme il lavorare all'interno di un
team Ecco Tutto questo a mio avviso è
indispensabile fondamentale per le
organizzazioni per poter ritornare ad
avere un apporto e un rapporto diverso
con i propri Talenti e quindi Ritornando
alla domanda iniziale ma sono veramente
ancora le aziende a scegliere i migliori
Talenti o sono forse i talenti a
scegliere le migliori aziende
le imprese negli ultimi anni hanno
investito tantissimo nei loro processi
di selezione e di valutazione ma forse è
arrivato il momento di ripensarli e
rivederli sapendo che il talento ha
selezionare e a valutare e quindi per
l'impresa diventa importante l'obiettivo
di essere la miglior scelta possibile e
quindi Qual è la risposta alla domanda
la risposta alla mia domanda Secondo me
è che oggi abbiamo
organizzazione e Talenti una grandissima
opportunità un'opportunità unica e
irrinunciabile che quella di trovare un
nuovo punto di incontro che quella di
confrontarsi su temi assolutamente nuovi
A mio avviso è un nuovo grande
grandissimo equilibrio che può essere
raggiunto portando l'organizzazione ad
ascoltare il talento e il talento ha
contribuire credo che da questa binomio
da questo incontro nuovo incontro di
domanda e di offerta del lavoro possa
scaturire un futuro sicuramente migliore
per il mondo del lavoro
grazie grazie